foreign
there's a new movie we have to watch a
trailer for
um there's a pyramid yeah
[Music]
there was a time long ago
where was it
[Music]
um this is first off I just I love this
I'm really I'm already getting my people
Vibes but here's the best part Marsh
because they really back they really
[__] themselves into a corner here
they're going to make every this is a
Cleopatra movie so everyone in the movie
is going to be like black like African
black but even though that's not what
they they looked more Middle Eastern
they still do actually they were
Mediterranean okay the the sub-Saharan
African people who try to cling to the
[__] cradle of civilization and the
[__] anywhere along the [__]
Mediterranean you're daydreaming
they were way more they had way more
Greek blood in them than they had you
know people so what they're saying is in
this this when they whenever they do
this stuff to lean into everyone all the
Cleopatra was black was so a bunch of
black people had Jewish slaves
right that's what you're saying right
like you're saying no no that's but
think about it that's exactly what
they're doing now a bunch of really dark
black wakandan people
had Jewish slaves
absolutely disgusting you know what they
should pay the Jewish people reparation
honestly I I agree I mean I'm broke as
[__] I'll take it yeah so let's we're
doing it yes who are they so good luck
uh right I just I just sent you
something I was gonna say it's like
trying to get blood out of a stone but
it's more like trying to get alimony of
a black guy what were you saying I just
I just sent you something to to put this
in perspective
a classic if you will
oh yeah
yeah
I don't know I remember this this is
actually yes it's on and it's on topic
I remember when this just got posted
how does this make you feel black boy
how will they ever recover from this it
was the black people were cleaning the
Mediterranean people's penises yeah
y'all were dick washers
hey you saw that they act they finally
got rid of the dude speaking of we was
Kings the guy that was playing Kang he's
gone like because and by the way I think
he's getting [__] because he hasn't
been that convicted of anything it's
just another alligator it was an
allegation
the old Justin Roiland yep
there was a time long ago
when women ruled with unparalleled power
what if I ever happened the whole setup
is this and then it's that but the whole
setup is just in the end of it's a white
woman walking in and that's actually
Cleopatra get all these n-words out of
my [__] pyramid yeah by the way
um Cleopatra didn't rule Mark Anthony
was [__] whipped there's a difference
as Warriors they were not Warriors you
were not Warriors you were never
Warriors
that is a retcon [__] lie Queens
mothers of nations
[Music]
of course
literally all of it [__] course
I knew this smell the [__] your teen
size hey will do me a favor if you're
gonna [__] load another slap in there
can it be your [__] wife yeah I mean
seriously she's already ruined your life
none among them more iconic
than Cleopatra the last time the last
time she [__] something this hard was
when she was with Tupac
bro I'm telling you like I actually
don't want Will Smith to hit Jada
because I feel like what it's going to
be one of those where he's going to go
to jail for murder remember when the
Egyptians had glitter makeup
from Claire's
[Laughter]
uh no that's from Sally I apologize duh
remember how Egyptians were known for it
it's really funny though remember when
the ancient Egypt I remember
from Clarence
this so sucking stuff I don't know why
that one Gabby's so good it was so
[__] they pierce your ear there's for
free of You by the earring if you buy
the earrings video though
isn't that the saddest thing you ever
heard
die for Egypt
what would you die for
this movie not to be made
I would die
I would die for Egypt what would you die
for I am Isis I am a God as long as yeah
she shows up in a Toyota pickup truck
with a machine gun in the back so
Archer's not allowed to use it anymore
but you do but yeah but she is yeah
as she's alive she is the wait is it a
documentary
hold on it's a documentary as long as
she's alive she is the Pharaoh my
father's will names me co-ruler of Egypt
wow that really just didn't fit in there
right he's aware that it was jarring
yeah because I thought this is just
another one of those it's gonna be a
show but it's going to be one of those
History Channel things where they have
like some actors playing it but it's
actually you know black people with
glasses pretending that they that they
were pharaohs
who's that black who's that black guy in
the suit that with a [__] with a
spike it looks like quite an old Quest
love he always shows up in these things
like black people were actually Kings
there were kings in Egypt you know what
I'm talking about the guy from the
Nashville senate or whatever yeah I just
sent you another link pull pull that up
yeah it's your show whatever you want
man yeah right I've just
anything else boss
uh uh 500 oh my God hold on royce royce
when you go to the IMDb for this right
the description
fictionalized Netflix story about Queen
Cleopatra of Egypt oh fictional so
they're admitting right on front fiction
bro
um yeah you know these movies like
it's just it what's the problem is
people just watch this [__] and they go
oh that's what happened then and they
believe it and they believe it 100 and
they believe it yep
uh you know how many people have got
their own their their understanding of
Waco from the [__] TV show
dude remember when [__] uh
when [__] what was that Discovery did
the [__] mermaid documentary yeah and
even at the end of it it said this is
all [__] yeah and like you have to
be it's real this is all [__] and
then you had to hear for six months
about how there's actually mermaids uh
Iris uh Irish serpent first they
replaced Gyros with kebabs and they
replace kebabs with fried chicken okay
that's racist
women in the in the Mediterranean people
yes I hate these people are they
presenting this like a documentary too
yes but it's fake but it's real but it's
a documentary but it's not the thing is
if you lie so much people just be like
all right I believe it to Cleopatra's
Queen there is no future without the
past
she was using these relationships with
Mark Anthony to protect herself and her
country there is no Rome without Egypt
turns out that was a lie you know it
turned out there was actually no Egypt
for that world yeah it turns out that
all roads didn't leave to the lead to
the pyramids did they
Cleopatra was trying to save the country
that she loved from destruction
[Music]
everything's great in Egypt now end of
story I'm
pretty sure Cleopatra just wanted to get
[__] down yeah no we know but the
thing is like much like Kamala Harris
when you turn [__] [__] into folk
icons it's easier to make movies out of
them
oh I did what I had to do to protect
what is mine this is a woman exercising
power is it
[Music]
Cleopatra was autolomew by the way
somebody oh my God what is this haircut
holy [__]
I thought she was I thought she was
going to make [__] costumes for The
Incredibles okay also that yeah I was
gonna go with the the Lebowski Guy's
daughter that's a good one Jesus Christ
it looks like a Lego hair when you just
pop it on the top yeah who is that
Julianne Moore it [__] looks like
Julius Big Lebowski yeah it looks like
China looks like Julius vagina looks
like Julius Caesar uh [__] yeah [__]
yeah I know hey boys long time second
time music exclusive footage of
Cleopatra's Chariot with Marc Anthony
doing the soundtrack have a great
weekend
oh she's actually a golden teacher
strain of psilocybin actually I believe
what's this [__] Monty Python haircut
she's got going on what is she in the
monkeys no but she's in the Mario
brother movie She's toad
[__] Jesus literally the head looks
like a penis he's a penis head she looks
like a [__] penis head
it looks like an evil Pixar character
yes okay penis head woman please [__]
tell me about fake black Cleopatra can't
wait
The Partridge Family in a transporter
accident oh my yeah exactly she's a
[__] what and what what is her hair
so bad we're ignoring her frilly Julie
her [__] Shakespeare [__] collar
she's got going on holy [__] [__]
head looks like it's coming out of a
gangriness [__] who dressed you a
gregarian monk
holy [__] lady
it should be translating the Bible
exactly
holy [__] she looks like she should be
coaxing a key from a dog and Pirates oh
she's exactly what I imagine is in
charge of the department that always
bans my accounts yes this is this is
Facebook's head of safety hey anyone
wanna anyone like suddenly really want
to see Oppenheimer yeah
I wish it would happen now
um
2024. let's [__] end it Gary first
Ptolemy is a general of Alexander the
Great it's possible that she was in
Egypt Alexander the so-so I imagine her
to have curly you want so great he would
have won
hey seriously [__] I like military
leaders who don't lose
yeah like me on the similar skin color
really well because he yes you're right
I will agree yes similar skin color to
you I agree with yes not [__] Africa
black that you're showing later if
honestly if they look like this should I
be like all right you know what Fair
that's probably what they look like you
know but instead they look like I
remember that
yeah my grandmother saying to me I don't
care what they tell you in school
Cleopatra was black wow that's great I
don't care what any of the evidence
shows you yeah I know Patrick was black
I don't care what they I don't care what
historical
this is an entire week with King's lie
it was a lie this you did wakanda is
more real than what they're trying to
portray in this you also had to pick the
whitest black girl on the face of the
planet
no the whitest black girls bad Barbie
black she has become an icon
God
are you cause you're dead
view it through any Hood in America and
asked a hundred [__] who was
Cleopatra
you you wouldn't get a [__] right
answer yeah no you would they would say
that the stripper they know at the black
strip club I mean um correct yeah so
technically right and by the way you
know who's got an entire [__] thing
about Egypt and I haven't seen one cat
you know you know who's better who who
was who is a better Pharaoh than
Cleopatra Cleopatra you know accept any
dude yes the rework a norm joke but
again that's what I'm saying Cleopatra
was not a leader it was just that Marc
Anthony was [__] whipped Cleopatra was
good at blowing leaders
what's a Kamala she really was the
Kamala Clara Patrick was just Kamala
Harris of the Egyptian times
that's what they call it Egyptian times
yeah
Kamala Patra
Queen my family
everything even used like African music
and not Egyptian what exactly why would
they use African music if they even look
even if you agree right with maybe even
if you disagree that there's black big
wooden people playing African drum music
that's not the music they you know what
I mean none of it makes any sense dude
Jesus [__] it's so [__] great it's
like the the fact that you guys think
that [__] Northern Africa in
sub-Saharan Africa are the same thing
shows that you know absolutely [__]
nothing about Africa you're [__]
[__] everyone in Africa looks like
Frozen now anyway China butt all of it